Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah like Rachel said i'm Hlynur Hallgrímsson i'm a senior data scientists within the office of data services, which is the centralized data science team here in the city of rhetoric,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I used to be an economist is still amateur economist, but i've been working as a data scientist since 2016 and a data analyst before that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I joined the certificate that Defense team in March of 2020 which was it was a short while can because,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The second week of my employment and we all could send them to call it so it's been like a rather remotes back and forth,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: back and forth between remote and,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Just in the office since then, but the steadfast in this new it was created in 2019 the end of 2019 and we're a small team so there's only six of us and low, sometimes we do like data products from start to finish, other times,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We are,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Essentially, brought into have with jax in other departments within the city of recovery,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But essentially our clients are other departments within the city,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So i'm going to talk to you about swimming pools, and a fan data science project that has to do with our swimming pools so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I think is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: accounts for a lot of large here rather have ISIS population or about 36% so the population of Iceland is 370 5000 people, but in a given 130 5000 and if you can't like the whole Capital Region,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like the suburbs, which are other,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like other municipalities, they are actually like 64% of all Icelanders like the Capital Region,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And we're pretty crazy about,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Our swimming pools,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So this is going to be about a project that is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: trying to do,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Trying to sell people,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: How crowded each swimming pool is but it's also just about how things are hard data science and it's not like that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You know, training, the most perfect,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: machine learning model is hard it's, just like the project, logistics and what we've come to call group into communication that's you know that's difficult sometimes,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This is just what i've gone through, but so we have,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: geothermal resources in the form of hot water so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We pump the water from the ground that 80 degrees Celsius so the hot water in essence is like incredibly cheap,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Which is like that one of the reasons why we have these proofs that they're actually you know reasonably they're not like this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: super fancy thing it's just everybody goes to a swimming pool and also,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Throughout the 20th century, one of the five people in Iceland was on average working in fishing so like a big part of,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You know, are just are coming of age story, as people is going to mandatory swimming classes through first 10th grade and like I noted that it's roughly 400 hours of mandatory swimming, which of course is like the worst version of everything is the mandatory version,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And also it's just called the dark so we like to get sunlight, we can,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: In the hot tubs,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And we also go to gossip and talk politics and just socialize,
Okay,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So the idea behind this project is telling people being able to convey to people which swimming pools are crowded and which ones are not so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like since the swimming pools are really popular,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: People have been contacting us and asking if there's any way to see like is there a website where you can see, like how crowded crowded, these are,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: and welfare workers have also expressed that interest for clients that are like success susceptible to sensory overload so that would be also cool feature once we implement this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But like a big thing was that a neighboring town happening it's like our local municipality competition they now offer a website dashboard which shows you how crowded there to swimming pools are,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But in their case they have staff manually count the patrons as far as i'm aware, but also during COVID swimming pool availability was cut to 50% of normal capacity for certain periods,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So when that became clear we realized Okay, this is something that we have to do not just you know to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It wasn't like it went from being like a nice to have something that we wanted to work on,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This is something that comes from the Department of sports and leisure within,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The city Reykjavik, and this is their pitch, but it's not a direct quote so they say okay so we've updated the gates or the turnstiles after swimming pools to modern electronic turnstiles,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: With these modern dates, you can now get information on how many people are asked each swimming pool through an API application programming interface and their Christmas Can you help us present this data,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: showing how crowded each police,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So this is essentially at that point, this is just like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Honestly, just like we figure it's a simple Shiny app and just a question of data, this, how are we going to present this if, like if you can just access the data tells us, the number of current visitors free to prove,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like I said, this is a project that is spearheaded by the Department of sport and leisure they come to the decentralized there doesn't seem to ask for help,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But with regards to getting the data, this is of course a little bit more complex, because department of sports and leisure has to deal with the Icelandic partner to the manufacturer of the gates,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And they are our contact,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Your contact partner for the actual vendor the gate manufacturer,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And this is, this is my train of thoughts, but still, it should be pretty straightforward once we get the data right and the clownfish sarah's put for emphasis,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, at the start of the project I envision this as a rather simple project you read the data from the API using the http are packets,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Of course we're going to be doing some typically using the type of person per so will visualize with GG plot make that visualization interactive with GG raft preferably and then make that into a reactive shiny APP and deploy it to other shiny x,io or RStudio connect,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And this, of course, is a tragic miscalculation on my part because,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: i'm assuming that Okay, the data might take some time because of this no communication and we are not like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah it's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's hard to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like make another team in like a company twice removed from you care about your product as much as you do, essentially, so they are not going to be,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: With like the internal fire that we have for this project at the data science team,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, with the five five item list i'm assuming a lot of things about the data and API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And just before we get into the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: nitty gritty of it like simple things like these projects can be time consuming because there are like difficult things or complex things but also the simple things,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: necessarily aren't necessarily simple because different groups have different priorities we have other priorities during the during working on this biggest was the Colbert dashboard that we,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: needed to put up and maintain the at the same time that we were like starting work on this and then there's group into communication,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And Mike forced communication protocols is this kind of maybe bad a bachelor's words but essentially it's like we need to talk to the Icelandic partner and they talk to the venture because essentially like the Icelandic partners,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Is the company that we buy the solution from,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then there's lawyers stuff when when lawyers between maybe the city of Reykjavik and the winter start talking, you can know things just to slow down,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So this is a timeline,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And it's absolutely horrible if you look at it, so the like the first idea to like we should maybe do this do this thing,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Is in February of 2020 and,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: there's like this request for data sent out hey can we access this API and you know lots of emails back and forth, and let me show you the emails,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Maybe just 20 emails from one like threat of emails that I,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Had a but it's not accounting for like meetings and stuff like that, but then you take you take into account like that between March and June we like we did not have our,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: eyes on this particular ball, because we were focusing on focusing on,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: putting up the Code, the dashboard and maintaining that and keeping that correct but,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: During the summer we start to push for more like what about this data we asked you know you said, this can you maybe look into that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And in September, we come to the conclusion, like Okay, you can get this data and here's how you so what would happen, but according you know, according to our lawyers,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: According to our lawyers you'd have to pay a fee to access this API and then the lawyers from sports and Lisa say no, no, according to our interpretation of this contract,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We don't actually have to pay this fee are talking about so that get there yeah gets in the way, but after Christmas start growing and we get the get the data,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But then we actually get the data, and this is this is citing last Friday,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And if you look at,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Look at this chart you can see that, for five of the six swimming pools in question, these are like strictly increasing these aren't showing us like how many visitors are at each swimming pool,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And it comes down to the fact that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: For five of the six pillars, like the hardware isn't able to come out it only comes in,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But for the sixth soon coolers know what you see there on the Left bottom corner,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It also looks kind of weird and we get into that in a bit, but essentially you can see that it's not strictly increasing,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So it turns out like I said the gatekeeper for these five pools can only completed there's into the booth so current visitors isn't current investors it's the cumulative sum of total visitors after that point during the day we're like at the point of time,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Where we sent the get requests to to the API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: there's more if you look at lawyers like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like this looks rather normal at like it passes the first eyeball test like okay this this looks like actual data but it's actually super weird if you look at like the end of the day, there are no people leaving the swimming pool,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like at the end of the day,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So when the pool closers and half an hour after the pool closest there are still around 275 people in the swimming pool according to the counter and we,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: get to that a bit later,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But essentially from this API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We don't know when the people leave we know when people come into the swimming pool, provided we are querying the API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So we asked ourselves what if we model, the duration of each visitor stay or rather it's five minute intervals, like, for all the visitors in each five minute interval because we're running the gap request to the API every five minutes and that way we can,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Essentially, get,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: If we put five minute intervals between the get request, we can say okay here are between 630 and 635 there were 20 people that actor our pilot,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: If you just know how long, on average, these people would stay in the proof for leaving we could essentially put together a data set this says okay here's an approximation of how many people are at the moment,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The big idea is that we request historical data through the ascending when winter and I like I said, but maybe it wasn't clear so i'll reiterate little slick has in and out data when it's not perfect it's just that the other five swing person only have enough data,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: To assumptions holt that people stace are not inherently different integration between lawyers and the other pools,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And the second assumption that people states are not inherently different integration between people who are counted out and people who are not counted out of letters lead, which we figured out is essentially the problem,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, like the real kicker is that some people are counted out of letters, but not often,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But if these assumptions hold and we get the historical data we figure we can train a model on historical learners look steady state durations of the people that are actually counted out and then the durations on to the life API data for the other 5%,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And that's what we did, and this is essentially like the sketches of how we did that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, within RStudio connected, we have an arm markdown document that is scheduled to run every five minutes,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It gets,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It gets the data from the LIFE API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And it also gets data from a pin we used to pins package,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: reads in the intent of that is essentially been read before okay this a terrible way to explain sorry okay so essentially every five minutes we read the LIFE data but also every five minutes we check for other like the historical,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Not,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Not the historical data that we were hoping to get from the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: vendor but, like every other API calls we've shifted to a pin that we pin to the art studio connect board, and then we join those together, so we can then rewrite over the pin,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And we then create the shine APP which read reads like let's say for today if the shiny airport to look at this in data, it would have an account of all like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: All the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: point in time counts for every every push,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And the shiny up then takes up another pinned object, which is a linear model,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then protects when these people would leave so you can present within the shiny APP an estimate of how many people are there,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And just to go into the like what we essentially did we started just on a local machine,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And once we've got access to historical data from the vendor would say save on Google cloud, we read that data from the query using the big earthquake packets but now we've used now we use the RStudio professional drivers and the dpi package,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We fit linear model for,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: predicting the duration and the predictors are he said the weekend,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: How like how long since the summer solstice or how long until the summer solstice and then we have a natural spline term of ours and we use,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: seven seven not for the slang term,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And it's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: we've toyed around with it, but essentially we based the like the number of knots on the staff knowledge so it's we're saying it's different,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: duration is influenced by, of course, what time of day, it is and we've fit the knots for the spline at this point in time, because they say okay it's different between 630 and nine so put a knot between not at 630 and another, not at nine and then they say, but also during the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: during lunch hours people stay like a much shorter time because these people that have maybe 45 minutes or an hour for lunches are very lucky and they went to the swimming pool to you know get a swimming,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And these people stay for a short time so that essentially the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's appropriate to fit not around the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: lunch time and so on, so it's, this is not something that we like we're,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We didn't have like some 15 where it was no decided by an algorithm we just talk to people that this makes sense, and then we evaluate the different combinations of knots on the training set,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, like I said the our markdown document is scheduled to read the data from the API key that data and rankle it into a table also read data from the in dataset pin,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then append the clean API data table to the in data set and then pin that updated in data set to the to the apart, which is what I was trying to show here,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We have done a shiny application that just reads that in the intersect in reads the model pin which we have deployed to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: RStudio connect from our trend on a local machine, but we deploy it to RStudio connect and then we run a particular function for that to create an estimate of current visitors, so this is an example of that this is data from September and,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Rather, reasonable,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: For the five points that we are focusing on but load the flag is still not good and,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We essentially we try to do some things which are not going to go into here we try to another linear model correct,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: That is like it didn't work out and the way we found out that it didn't work out was we essentially came this APP to the managers of the swimming pools to evaluate and they said,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: These five pools there they're okay they're actually like they were really happy with it, but let us know it wasn't even close,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So that's something we have to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We still have to figure out,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But like, why is this a cool thing because, in my opinion, is super cool because it's all our and RStudio connect so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like we're in our shop here to data science team, and if it's all our we can move at their own pace, and for this part of the project, there were no outside constraints or you know inefficiency in how we communicate with our groups,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And we also get to run into the problems ourselves,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then we know what to take into account is parts of the process, our outsource be on the team and we've actually had this like a way to explain it is to think about like building a car and I told her to this before essentially we're thinking about,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: If we are trying to build the car, there are many components that need to be best and essentially we are saying we can put a professed prototype and do everything ourselves,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And that way, we know there's there's no chance of US running into a problem if we outsource to another team let's say,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You take this part of the project let's say in the example of a car you create that, like the seats for the car,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then we get that back and we realize okay this didn't fit they need to talk to us, but if we just do this ourselves, we run into that problem ourselves and when we've built like a rather you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: crummy version of the car,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: As like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like a minimum viable product, we can then say Okay, we need to outsource this thing we need to follow protocols with God with regards to reading the API and then we outsource that to our it team,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But then we can say here's what we ran into and here's what you need to take into account and that way we get results so much faster,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So this is our current setup,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So we are not actually reading from the API,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Using RStudio connect now we put into what methods were, which is an integration platform which our it team uses so that's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: that's just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Protocol and it's it's just like super convenient for us because it gets written to our as your data like storage and, or rather the entire data,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: That is created every five minutes that gets written to assure data like and we can then read that in our our markdown document every five minutes, and then we do a prediction,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Based on the linear model which is still just a pin on RStudio connects because there's like no need to complicate that and then we have a prediction table, which is what the shiny operates,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: On like when you fire up the shiny if you're just reading from one,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: One table, which is the like the prediction table, which is a pin on our student conduct apart on our student conduct,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But just before we finish up,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I want to talk about leadership because that's like that's super interesting problem,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And like I said here, the date the pillar is absolutely well,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And like you say it's a technical term, and that has everything to do with how nice the staff are so like I said it's the only it's the only pool that comes in and out but,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: When there are say school kids who go to their mandatory swimming,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like let's say there's a row, or a queue of for the school kids trying to leave a swimming pool after the swimming classes,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The stuff after this layer is not going to require everybody to take their like their arm fant,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: embraced it rather and put it into the machine which then consider okay this individual came in,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: 90 minutes earlier they're leaving now it just opened the like open the gates and the kids throw these bracelets into like a bucket by the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: By the actress essentially and it also has to do with like late at night when there's a lot to do, they don't make people actually wait for you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: waste their time in the queue so it's all due to kindness and you can read that phrase Daniel kindness you ruined my death and the voice of the British comedian comedian which a customer can,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You can do it to yourself, but,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So the things we're trying, of course, the first thing we wanted to do was just ask the vendor to make changes to the API to separate the Internet from the outer data flow to slack we're still waiting on this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But in the meantime we have you know, because we really want to do we really want to get this thing out we've been working on for a long time, so one idea was to use a secondary,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like another counter that is located by the actual pools in Lotus learn not by the entrance, but this has proven unfruitful because,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's just a traffic computer it doesn't say that people are going in this direction or in this direction so it's just we can't tell you how many people are going into the boot and how many people are going out of the book,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then, this is like a pardon pardon my English or rather pardon my French for what i'm about to say, but this like the next thing feels like something agreed on the Twitter the Twitter account Internet of shit which is like an Internet of Things like it we're roast these smart solutions,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But there are smart lockers and lawyers leg but, like the Internet have set apart, is where it's unclear if the firmware can be updated to the most recent version to support life data so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: For time being we only have historical data for this markers which I believe gets written to a database every night when the purchaser close, so this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, essentially, we tried a couple things that didn't work we're waiting on the vendor to make changes to API and i'm sure it's it's going to be no,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Oh, let the lawyers talk to lawyers about this, he it'll end up some and take it herbicide,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But also before and like this year was a gross oversimplification we're only talking to like the Icelandic partner to the vendor,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: There are also gyms that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: have access to the pool, so there, so you can go to a team that's like located next to a pool, and they have separate counters into the pool so after you've,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: done your workout at the gym you can actually walk through some tunnel into the pool area and we have yet to figure out how to compose because,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: that's we deal with department of sports and leisure and department of sports and leisure these with the owners of the gym and the owners of a gym talk to some Icelandic partner to have enter which talk to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You know, international enter so it's like a more complex like pipeline essentially pipeline of information,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So still to do we need to account for like Jim patrons that use us whimpers adler's load and breadth of slack and, like the final point of this presentation is of course there's gonna be something else, but we don't know it yet so i'd love to take questions on this i'm sure,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah we have 20 minutes and i'm sure there are some things that I did not explain properly so i'm all yours,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much, Hlynur that was awesome and i'm just thinking it's lunchtime here would be so cool to be able to just go to a pool right now,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So there's a lot of great questions that came in on slide oh and and so,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Just so everyone knows and josiah can help me share the link again, you can ask questions there if you want to put your name in I could also call on YouTube like add additional context to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But i'll start with some of the anonymous ones and one was quite a few people commented that they really liked that first visualization you shared,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And he said, could you kindly share the syntax of the first visualization that showed your email tracking the day we requested the daily receive,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay, yes, so this is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This presentation is like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: An hour marketing presentation, so the timeline it's essentially three CD plot graphs and I can share this I should have added my github account but i'll share this like this is this oh like i'm terribly sorry i'm not sharing the screen i'm sharing that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Sharing the chrome browser the,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Presentation screen,
Okay,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: i'm gonna i'm gonna share the secondary screen, so I can like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: to share screen,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay, hopefully,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I can share,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): It with the recording,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Oh, now I can see the code,
Okay,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay, so this is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like this is just a data and it's like this is the first GG plot and it's just a mess, but I didn't think i'd be sharing this code, but i'd be happy to like data realism so yeah i'll put that on my github and Rachel you can share that okay thanks,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, and someone else asked is there a live link to the swimming pool dashboard currently,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: At not that is accessible outside like the city of very good team, because we haven't because of our problems with lawyers,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Currently, there are two Apps one APP is for,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: managers of the swimming pools, and the other one is like the in progress, because I had like I make the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The plane looking shiny but then we have,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: sold who's a data scientist of great data scientists there at the city very good like this artistic guy and he makes like all the pretty production Shanghai APP so that one is hopefully you know, soon to be released, but at the moment no it's not accessible,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, and also, if people have questions you want to ask live as well i'm just going to allow people to unmute themselves to, and if you want to raise your hand, you can jump into,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And, but I will go to the next anonymous question unless anyone has one you want to ask live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay um one is did this project initiate any improvements and user tracking,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Or is everybody just content with the way you patch the problem and things will stay the same, I think you may be mentioned at the end about API possibly changing,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah but another thing is that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like there have been,
Like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: discussions between sports and leisure and the managers of the actual swimming pools with regards to change,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like it's perfectly acceptable for 3040 school children to not be counted out, but like for the later like if there's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Two full grown adults waiting in queue like you can they're sensitive saying you know we'd appreciate, if you stop the kindness just a little bit, and you know, let these people be counted up so that's something that we haven't seen in the data, yet, but, provided that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It provided that we fix things with like, once we get the gym data, and then we can say like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Can we look at this if if they were to like be more,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: or less less less kind know become people have,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, I I love when you talk about like the people behind the data and thinking about like who those actual individuals are and what they're doing as they go about their day yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Another outvoted question was could you compare your use of plot Lee and G giraffe Am I am I pronouncing that package correctly, did you use both or prefer one over the other,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I actually I started out using plotted because i've been using that for a long time, but then so who's this you know artistic data scientists that I mentioned earlier, he,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: pointed me in the direction of giraffe and i'd much I much prefer that now because, like we just created a GG plot, and then you wrap it in the GG rough and it's it's instantly became comes,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like an interactive issue section provided you change the like the G on part so it's it's I like the GG plot like floating, and this is like a perfect extension to that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): cool Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'd love to hear from other people to say you don't have to just keep hearing my voice,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Do you want to ask questions live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I see Grégoire,
Grégoire Mansio: can you hear me well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, I can,
Grégoire Mansio: yeah Okay, thank you Hlynur for the great presentation nitrogen I am an economist to so that's,
Grégoire Mansio: that's nice to know that,
Grégoire Mansio: i'm not the only one interested in data science and I wanted to know how much the the city of the public entity is interested in,
Grégoire Mansio: All of what you can provide as that Dan at the store economy store, I mean are there many projects are willing to put you in or it's like still growing, as you mentioned, because it's it's new to them,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: awesome question, thank you,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's it's actually just like skyrocketing,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, like I said the team is relatively new,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like your sent 2019 but, but now like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: At the beginning, there were we didn't have these like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Fixed protocols in place, how we did this project, but now just with a little experience we've been like moved into the it,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It departments framework for like this is the way we accept projects, and this is how we allocate the time to them,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And like since that it's it's become like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: made it's been made clear to the departments within the city of very giving like here's a team of data, scientists, if you have,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: An interesting use case or something urgent which you want them to do here's how we would go about getting them in and it's like people are super interested in doing that, and it has to do with like you do you do one cool thing for like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The Department of schools and the next and after that they're like Okay, we like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: They of course know, like the potential, but then when when you hand something off to them, they see Okay, this is something that's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like this is something that it's now available it's like really essentially so yeah like super super interesting,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: All things data currently,
Grégoire Mansio: Okay, very cool very cool, thank you very much thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you Jay one I see you asked a question on slide oh and and put your name there can I pass the MIC over to you to add some context there yeah,
Jiwan Heo: Sure i'm just wanted to know how the teamwork or delegation works within your team, do you face any limitations, because you're in the public space yes wondering how the teamwork delegation works,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay, great Christian like like I said there's only six of us, so we have our chief data officer in,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And she's like the head of the operation, but we have a data engineer, and we have me a data scientist and my my skill set is mostly geared towards predictive modeling but also you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: analytics you know report, something that needs to be done, and then we have circuit who's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: he's like a super machine learning engineer type of data scientist is like so competent at that, but he's also like this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: he's our go to guy to like finalize the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: New shiny Apps and do like this complex data visualizations match stuff and things like that, and then we have Cindy who's also a data scientist and she is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: She is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Doing More of the report things,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Currently,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: As our like our junior scientists,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then we have creamer who's also data engineer, so we have simply through data scientist to end engineers and the chief data officer and the tasks that Paula,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: creamer the data engineers, they are split more along the lines of like which departments, the data comes from,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's a rather complex conversation but, like the between the science of data scientists it's more like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: focused on like what we're good at like serious really good at, not just you know shiny applications that are like doing reports but, like other things like power bi and clicks and stuff like that so yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
and
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You have your hand raised as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and pass it over to you,
Saif Haque: Thank you Rachel,
Saif Haque: for giving me the chance,
Saif Haque: And my apologies if,
Saif Haque: I might have missed this right in the beginning, what i'm wondering is it's quite an interesting project, but the thing that i'm curious about is that what was the,
Saif Haque: what's the problem that you're trying to solve with this project and what was the business case for this, if there is a strong business case for it,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah so I didn't show that yeah did I show this slide i'm not sure if I showed this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: slide so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's it's essentially,
Like the first,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The first thing that like sparked this idea was just citizens trying to figure out, which was so crowded and sending you know coming into the city offices, is there a way to show,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: US which cannot, you know, can I tell if legislators super crowded right now and it's just this interest with start the conversation, but then, once we you know that idea sparked i've also talked to welfare workers within the city very quick and they are like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Essentially, because if they have clients that have like are susceptible to sensory overload lot they usually go to like really remote swimming pools, like in the after the suburbs like clear perks like which is not one of the posing questions here, but essentially just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Just to make sure,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: That they're at the non crowded booth and then,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like COVID came and that's when the project actually,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You know, became an actual project, although we like we don't have 50% CAP capacity now it's only for like two one month periods,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But that's when they were actually like the lines outside the swimming pools, and the idea was if we can get this you know up and running fast enough, we can then show people okay this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This pool is currently too crowded for you to go there, but here's a pool that is actually like not credit except, these are not not sadly like it's great that we don't have these limitations anymore, but like we didn't manage to do it within that you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Two months,
Saif Haque: So I guess,
Saif Haque: Going forward now that that explains a lot actually Thank you I think i've seen something similar in terms of people trying to check how the crowded the supermarkets are so,
Saif Haque: yeah going forward if you could probably link it with the booking system for the swimming pool, then you might end up with a really,
Nice,
Saif Haque: Business backing for that so now that's great project, thank you,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Thank you so much, and like that's that's like a fighter fighter plan, but,
Saif Haque: You already have everything in,
Saif Haque: A couple of months time,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah but, like the booking system is is connected to the so you can actually if we were to you know team up with it, we could actually,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: join forces and within this APP you can not only see which are like which proofs are crowded and not crowded, you could actually like buy a ticket so yeah awesome Thank you,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): He only has his hand is raised as well, and then i'll go over to some of the,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Other anonymous questions he only,
Óli Páll: hi what is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It,
Óli Páll: guys again and i'd like to add also that the city of regular is on this digital transformation journey,
Óli Páll: And so the requirements are also coming straight from the business, so we have these digital leaders scattered around the business,
Óli Páll: And they know their stuff and they come come to the data team and the Department of innovation services with projects that they have prioritized based on you know their operational needs, but you know i'm here for question now,
Óli Páll: really close friends, since, like everybody knows everybody here they like five of us here and lesson,
Óli Páll: So,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I should add that only is our former chief data officer, which you know created this team of inventors, as I saw someone call it in the chat,
Óli Páll: And you certainly are but you,
Óli Páll: i'm allowed one difficult question,
But i'm not good,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But i'm wondering answer it,
Óli Páll: i'm I want to have a discussion on like I think this is super interesting for the people, joining this call is so,
Óli Páll: So we're building this prediction model for for predicting how many people are visiting the pools and what's the level of accuracy that is needed for that, in terms of,
Óli Páll: Like value for the business from there for the proof business So could you could you enlighten us on that because we have we have this so often but i'm gonna,
Óli Páll: because I feel that it's super important for data science projects are you, is it valuable to predict whether they have visitors or one is like is this difference does this since something will me but isn't the value like predicting whether or 50 or 500 words and yeah,
Óli Páll: Actually, pays for talking about prediction accuracy in terms of value taken away yeah,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Thank you so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The thing we did like we,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We evaluated,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: These models on training data, but we don't have test data because we're not going to ask the staff there to you know count every five minutes and create a test data set for us, but rather what we did was,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: leave it up to the managers and the staff of the swimming pools, to look at the act and essentially they would be like the gauge, if this is accurate enough for them and The thing is, they like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The one case where they were doing like the standard spot checks okay it's 2pm you walk around the swimming pool and tell me how many people there are, and we can then Compare that to the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: To this APP that this data science team has given us and what they found out was like it was,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like in like well within their like margin of reasonable accuracy, because it like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Only alluded to it doesn't matter if there are 70 or 75 people at the swimming pool, but it does matter if it's 75 or 200 people so like one example was like we get the spot check it was 72 but the model showed 76 will completely fine with that, and you know so that essentially like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This is what made it fun, because, as only knows at my last place of employment, I was like always you know doing these,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: increasingly complex,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: machine learning algorithms,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Just to get like you know point oh 7% accuracy increases and that's like that's not the fun stuff but, like the fun stuff is you know doing a,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: project like a complete project and saying okay here's like this,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: here's our estimate and we're not trying to you know, was it squeeze blood out of the stone i'm not sure if that's even an English expression that is an Icelandic so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So it's yeah it's fun it's got all i'm gonna say like working on a project that it it doesn't matter if it's 72 or 76 is just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Well, was on the margin,
Óli Páll: Three sort of upbringing, the like correct level of accuracy for value the value, full of business like you mentioned in and talk and I really like that this is like we evaluate our models through discussions with with our stakeholders, that was an awesome presentation, thank you,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You are awesome Thank you,
Óli Páll: you're awesome,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: good to see you again,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So a few other anonymous questions on in here if it's Okay, if we go over a little bit,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Did you have to run,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It would be fun okay,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome and for anybody who missed it i'll share the recording as well, so they can get their answers to that one was what was it hard to set up the azure or aws whichever cloud provider used with RStudio connect and scale it up for production,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: If it's regards to setting up RStudio connect,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: On our sure,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: that's like that's beyond my comprehension that's something that the data engineers did but getting RStudio connect to talk to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Our shared data like like storage container is super easy and it's the same for just you know doing it on your essence your local machine so that's been something that's been kind of a surprise,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: In that I can I can use the pinch packets, so I can set up a pin board on our city RStudio connect and I can set up another pin board on,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: A shared data lake so I can then use like the same in underscore get function to get data from the data like and data from RStudio connect but the way we,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: eventually ended up doing it was using a package called assure store from the Microsoft employees, an open source package just on crime,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And that's essentially how we read the data currently into into RStudio connects just you know there's a couple of it's like it's not a one liner but, like the pen CAP,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But maybe three or four lines of code so it's been really, really nice and sorry and the key to that is like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Setting the environment variables in RStudio connect so don't store any like credentials in your code,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You alright let's see let's got a few other questions still here what package you use for the model,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So this is like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: A super simple,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like linear splines model so essentially the only packages, we use us for the modeling or just you know if you tell,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It probably starts the House the island function and then this plans packets would test the nutters blends assumption, but then we used yardstick from type models to just do the evaluations of,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: of accuracy on the training data,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Is there a way to manually remove the end data for wow and someone's gonna make me pronounce this pool longer slurred in our,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Sorry, is there a way to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): their way to manually remove the in data,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And if anyone I know is anonymous but, if anyone wants to add any other context feel free to jump into,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So it's like I think I understand the question and the problem is that we we can't do it because what we see is like the difference,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Between five minute interrupts so essentially if if minus two people are recorded as the change between let's say 630 and 635 we have no idea, looking at the data to tell if that minus two is because you know, nobody,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: actor support, but two people left or if, like 10 people entered the pool and 12 people last sadly,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The data doesn't allow us to do that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Could you let us know what other data science projects you currently are working on or have plan, other than the swimming pool and koba dashboard,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So one of the things is estimating like the need for personnel at our call Center that's something that's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: That we're working on low it's not a priority priority currently but,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: There are like in depth reports regarding just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Not like a COVID dashboard but you know the economic variables regarding you know, the effect of COVID we have that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: it's supposed to report and we've done like a dashboard for that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But essentially like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like this 40 page or markdown document that we update,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And then hand into like City Hall, essentially, and there are we did this deep dive into like the costs of,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Essentially, just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: don't know what the English term for this, but essentially like if,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: If there are any special needs,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: In you know school districts and it was essentially a deep dive into,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Looking if there were,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: unintended essentially biases if if some groups of students were being,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: getting more financing of special needs and others and stuff like that so it's it's all kinds of things,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I great question here for others on the call who maybe are going through the very beginning stages of this process, how did you get administration to buy into RStudio connect and how did you get around data protection issues,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: like this has a lot to do with only we saw earlier he's now like a suit and tie type of guy running things, and you know as a manager, I think, like the key thing is that he's like a PhD in statistics and has been using our since 2006 so he understood,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The importance of allowing people with specialized skill sets to like use the tools that are most suited for that,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So he wasn't going to say Okay, but here's this other solutions that you know we can save a couple of bucks on but you know you're up out of your element, and I think it's just,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Not every place is going to have like somebody that moves moves that person being a data scientist into the management role and then can influence decisions like that, but I think,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I think it has a lot to do with just communicating like you hired us, because we have these particular skill sets and we're not like it's like this thing, where you know somebody,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Somebody isn't our programmer but then they come to this new place and they say oh we're like can't you do this in Python and then I have to like become this superpower Python program instead of using the superpower of you know, having worked in our for like the last 10 years or whatever,
I,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just remembered I forgot to make an announcement earlier and I apologize for that to the lander analytics team, but I did want to let everyone know that there's also an R in government conference coming up soon, so I wanted to see that before a few other people have to to run,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And they're the lander analytics team is actually so kind to provide us a 20% promo code for anybody who attended the meetup so i'm going to share that on the meetup page as well, but the conferences on December 9 and 10th,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So i'll i'll share the link in the chat window to if anyone wants to check it out, but it seems like it would align very well with,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): The meetup today and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And for a bunch of people who are in the government space, but if anyone from lander analytics is on and you want to jump in and provide any more info feel free to do so too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And my bad for not saying that earlier i'll share the link in in just a second,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Cleaner there's two other questions left, and I know you touched upon this one little bit, but it was for this project what profiles were involved into constructing all this,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Not only the data science team, but stakeholders and technical team,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay yeah so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The profile meeting,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: i'm sorry,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I think I think,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): They need to like i'm i'm assuming so feel free to jump in I know it was anonymous but thinking about this project specifically and getting that from from zero to into production,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Who are the stakeholders that you had to work with, and who are the technical teams that you had to work with to get that done as well,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: awesome Thank you,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: i'm showing you mess no i'm not seeing the screen Okay, thankfully, I so,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The the two big ones were like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: At the Department of sports and leisure, there are like there is like a like a meanie it department and we essentially report to them, but they also have pushed with communicating to you know vendors and partners or vendors, but then within the Department of it, we also have to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: We needed to move the API requests to the like the centralized integration platform, so there is a special it's called web methods this integration platform, so we had to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Essentially, deal with them, but the there are,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Perhaps not,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Production of stakeholders, essentially, but like comrades,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: But,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I think, like the the two largest stakeholders are essentially the I this like mini it team at the Department of sports and leisure and the managers of the swimming pool because there's,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: A manager off each swim because these are like rather large establishments and,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: I,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Because, essentially, we are hoping to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: make their lives,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: somewhat easier, also the staff at the screen because because my,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: provide the disk goes as planned and people actually start to look words credit, you know it's hopefully going to be more distributed across all the posts,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: i'm not sure if that answered anything really, but it was my attempt at that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): was helpful to me but feel free to unmute yourself if you have any follow up questions on that too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): One of these days we'll all be in person and will feel more comfortable i'll like talking as a group, maybe at a our cto conference one day we'll have these,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): birds of a feather groups again,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): The other question is how did you communicate the need for staff hours for future projects,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So, for example, with only six people right now, and this interest in data projects growing,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Will you need to kind of advocate for for more data scientists,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This is like this is kind of you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: The secret sauce of this project is that it because it was agreed to before like the,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: workflow was finalized with regards to allocating you know the resources of data scientists,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: This has been kind of you know it's been,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It wasn't put in a box essentially it wasn't it wasn't some,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: These are the man hours that are allowed to end it and it's not like, but of course that that's also part of the shortcomings of this project, because if it had been,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: You know, put in a box and just scoped as a project like we do now, now that we've moved into that phase of our operation,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It we we probably would have like ran into these like speed bumps much earlier,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Instead of just you know, accepting the project assets and diving into it and then it kind of becoming a side project, because you know,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Because it is a rather weird project i'll jump on to it when I have nothing else to do when you know when when when there's like Oh, you can get this state or you can get this connection, like from the gyms and stuff like that I can you know I can kind of treat that as a,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Side project with,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Sorry, with less oversight, then, like the regular project, but at the same time we like if we had put this into the formalized process and sculpt it i'm sure we would have,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like because now it's been like okay here's the problem, we ran into let's talk to the Department of sports leisure,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And they'll go Oh, why don't you like the secondary counter let's try that and we go Oh, we didn't know, there was a secondary content, nobody told us that and when that doesn't work like Oh, why did you want to try to,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like the smart you know locks in the load of saying like Oh, nobody nobody told us that they were smart locks so it's been like a blessing, and the curse that this has been kind of like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: A rather unofficial project, so to speak,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, and just you mentioning that, like these side projects was making me think about something which I think is really cool that your team does on Fridays,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): where you have like the chance to work on like anything that you want to and was curious if you could just tell us all a little bit more about that too,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Like i'm the least like you'll get the least interesting answer out of me, because you know it's got a previous project,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: So, but like just a name so sore our data scientist he's his he's been like focusing on getting up to speed with D3 and you know, taking graphs that are based on data and are and then putting that into like a javascript to create a D3 block, which is something that he's passionate about,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: And and it's gonna be,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: super nice thing for us move forward,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I also know that the team part of the team's mission or information you had shared with me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Probably a year back was that you want to hopefully be able to like help other cities do something similar and kind of,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Create maybe a working group, among other people using our and public sector different data science teams and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just wanted to open up the conversation about that if if anybody wants to jump in to really just see like what would be the best way for us to all start to do that and be able to network with each other and share best practices,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I think the meetups are great for being able to like highlight different use cases and ask questions but i'm thinking like on a going forward basis,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Is that some kind of like slack channel or a linkedin group, what would be helpful to you all, are what ideas do you have,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It just like before is anybody I can't see if anybody's raising their hand,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): not yet,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It seems like you like,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Some of that is,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: going on in linkedin groups now which I didn't think was,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: It didn't seem like like a viable solution to me some months ago, but a lot of things are moving in that direction,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see Mon Dieu just recommended that as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Maybe we could start with testing that out to and just for people who joined this event as well and to invite other people going forward,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Does anyone else have any other ideas for how to do that, or how to better connect people,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I want that's a great point as well there's also that I find the slack channels on the are for data science online learning Community really helpful to, and so I will ask john who moderates that if we could create,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Like a government channel as well,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: yeah that'd be really, really good,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And that's if anybody is not in that slack channel, you can always just join it by going and i'll put the put the link in the chat window but it's just our four DS the ios last join,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see someone had unmuted if you have anything else to add to yes, I also,
소병현: Nice to meet you thanks for your presentation today and yeah because I,
소병현: i'm kind of like old school by I prefer also face to face communication meeting meeting the person who's working in that field,
소병현: And had this experience asking the question directly but those kind of our Conference, maybe we can have that third is cool big,
소병현: disappeared i'm not sure it's going to disappear, but after it gets better because one of the things that you post it to our Conference which is pretty expensive and yeah it's it's to me,
소병현: Should should work good work, not some hundred dollar hundred dollar show I think it's better for us to have some kind of opportunity meeting people in the field and sharing the opinions of it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Definitely and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Hopefully we all,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): will be able to meet at conferences again soon as well, but I do think a really good thing that came out of the past two years, as well as these virtual events is that anybody can join and it's open to everyone and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): free of cost, obviously, but if I can ever help be like the middle person and they're introducing people are i'm also happy to do that so i'm a professional Community manager here at RStudio that's my new title as of six months ago,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So always feel free to reach out to me directly to on linkedin or i'll put my email in the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And i'd love to be able to help connect people and maybe if that's a like virtual coffee or we have like smaller group chats as well to talk about specific challenges that you're facing or I don't know something specific like shiny optimization,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): happy to to help set that up and organize it for people to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I know we got into all the questions on slider and we are definitely way over linear so thank you so much for staying on and answering all the questions I do want to just do one last check to see if anybody else on has anything that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You want to ask or things you'd like to see or feedback as well be great to hear from you all,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just want to say thank you so much lennar for an awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): presentation,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): it's so cool to be able to dive deeper into the,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): story well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I think the audience,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: would just want to say,
Hlynur Hallgrímsson: Okay, just if anybody wants to like talk on linkedin or whatever like please add me, and you know answer any questions, and you know learn from you, and vice versa, so thanks everyone,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Perfect well Thank you so much thinner have a great guest today really appreciate it, and thank you all so much for joining,